il était midi je fais un super départ un
super start
j'étais à peu près en 5 6e position et
j'arrive sur cette fameuse bosse pour
moi lâcher les gaz pour perdre une demi
seconde c'était trop c'est énorme mais à
ce moment là j'ai pas conscience que
lâcher les gaz et perdre une demi
seconde pour le reste de ma vie m'a
finalement c'est rien donc là je garde
les gaz je prends l'appel du saut à ce
moment là la moto m'éjecte et l'aja
terrible sur le bas du dos et je sens un
grand crac dans la moelle épinière
ensuite on me rapatrier en france et là
ma première question quand je suis
arrivé en france j'ai regardé le médecin
le chirurgien qui est venu voir dans là
dans ma chambre et je vais je lui dis
docteur dites-moi est-ce que je vais au
marché alors mois déjà c'était mon rêve
j'avais j'avais qu'une seule idée en
tête j'allais voir mes parents tout le
temps quand j'étais petit j'étais papa
maman je veux être pilote de motocross
quand je serai plus vieux mes parents me
disaient c'est bien axel il faut croire
en tes rêves
si tout se dérouler correctement bah oui
j'aurais pu avoir une longue carrière
devant moi avec des titres avec une vie
un peu de super star dans le monde de la
moto partir peut-être même aux états
unis
et là durant demain tu te retrouves avec
des jambes qui partent n'importe comment
qui ne fonctionnent plus dans un
fauteuil roulant en plus moi je suis
quelqu'un de très grands donc au début
c'était très dur déjà dur de voir revoir
le monde en fauteuil
parce que tu as l'impression de ce que
tout le monde te regarde de haute était
tout petit ça fait bizarre c'est quelque
chose que les gens ne pensent pas mais
aller l'été à la plage dans l'eau quand
tu es en fauteuil bah c'est tout
c'est toute une aventure parce que le
fauteuil dansable je t'explique pas
parce que la mise à l'eau c'est la
galère parce que bah tu dois faire
attention parce que je sens pas mes
pieds donc tu te coupe avec des cailloux
des coquillages et une coupure ça met
des mois à guérir
donc parfois les tu penses tu réfléchis
à deux fois à dire est ce que ça vaut le
coup d'aller dans l'eau pour après avoir
plein de problèmes durant les mois à
venir je me force à le faire et
finalement je profite du coup je profite
de l'instant présent dans l'eau je me
dis va il faut que je profite deux fois
plus qu'une personne valide parce que
moi je vais galérer sur le chemin retour
donc je profite
sans trucage sans trucage
miley prothèse quand même le kosdaq
l'oubliera pas trop vite là j'arrive pas
à filmer la va pas trop vite va pas trop
vite
[Musique]
en fait quand je suis sorti du centre
d'éducation batta mille questions dans
la tête et là je me suis dit mais il
faut que je me lance quelque chose ça
peut être reprendre des études faire du
reprenait job et là je me suis dit non
il faut que je me lance un challenge des
sports c'est toute ma vie
et là je vous ai dit ok les jeux
paralympiques de rio 2016 et la bam je
suis parti à fond ça a été très dur
faut savoir que genève seulement avec
les bras donc imaginez vous remettre
dans l'eau sans usage de vos armes en
disant à son coach qu'il en cinq ans je
dois être champion paralympique
elle m'a pris pour un malade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu envie de revenir dans les sports
mécaniques la envie de rejoindre une
nouvelle fois mes copains avec qui roule
en moto qui maintenant le fond paris
dakar avait en voiture donc ça me permet
de pouvoir finalement retrouvé un peu ma
vie d'avant et de pouvoir aller les
titiller
j'ai mes acteurs ici qui me tiennent mes
chevilles à 90 degrés donc ça me permet
de pouvoir faire le rôle des muscles des
mollets et donc on mâche vie qui est
bloquée je peux accélérer et freiner à
l'aide de ces at-elle comment félicité
un à forcément il ya des vibrations il
ya des sceaux il ya des trous donc ça
bouge vraiment dans tous les sens donc
l'idée c'est d'être vraiment bloqué avec
streit 1 sur l'accélérateur
[Musique]
comme j'étais un athlète de haut niveau
et comme je faisais déjà beaucoup de
sport un peu extrême ba aujourd'hui
forcément je suis un peu frustré de ne
plus pouvoir pratiquer certains sports
donc certes j'essaye de m'adapter pour
alléger pas faire du buggy faire de la
mini bike ou des choses comme ça mais tu
as toujours cette ce frein ou le
handicap te rattrape finalement
et oui j'ai fait des choses
extraordinaires différentes certes mais
j'aimerais tellement pouvoir remettre
mes fesses sur une moto et faire comme
on dit dans le jargon un whip sur un
saut de fou et malheureusement ça c'est
des choses que peut-être je pourrai plus
jamais faire
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je suis allergique
[Musique]
si j'avais message à dire à l'axel à 20
ans je lui dirais de ne pas lâcher les
gaz ça peut faire ça peut paraître
bizarre ça peut paraître fou en n'ayant
pas lâcher les gars j'ai eu un accident
mais aujourd'hui je partage énormément
de valeur des valeurs puissante des
valeurs qui peuvent inspirer la personne
qui peut être être à l'hôpital en
difficulté une personne qui ne croient
plus en la vie et aujourd'hui je le
prends plus comme une mission où je me
dis pas ce qui m'est arrivé je dois le
partage est une toile transmettre aux
autres parce que tout le monde peut y
arriver